いや日や通すことでスマホやタブレット pc の指1本で楽に持てるスタンドにも
でき
落下ポーチにもなる便利なリング
ダンカーリング後ろが主になってて今を張ってるんですけどはがすと粘着部分になって
i メンターにこうハルト
今指を通すだけでスマホが指一本で持てるという
メリアイテムですまさにこんな感じだね公園つけ方をします ipad とかにも普通
につけれます母をこういう感じでもこうなるとでも ipad も指一本で操作できて
&ガーリーにもなります
ています
やべ
はーいじゃあそんなバンカーリングなんですけども僕こそバンカーリングいい群の可能
性を感じておりますってこい
お前らー
ええええええ
という意味でこちらに wandering 20個準備しますこちらのバンカー
リング10個で何をしようかといいますと
止めちゃく旅行作り戻る持ち上げますよ
ん無理だった ipad がラクラク持ち上がるんでかなり強いです
この居酒屋を使ってだったりに軸を天井で貼り付けて僕はやら中でブランクを作りたい
アナがね一直線上になるわけですよこういう感じで想像してくださいこういう感じで
ちょっと先祖にしてほになお東芝製その名はにいたをつけるともに俺が乗ったのさー
もう良い訳残念されるください今日は最低は困難です
まどろむアクセサリーでブランコはできるなんて誰も思いつかない制裁は本会は受信
ありますねこれすっごい粘着力ですよ選挙1カーリングでおうちに滑り台じゃない方
まずミスグラップを作ろうと思いますでは行こう
頭しかねぇ chou 一間しょっちゅうラブーブランコやの入った天井これで簡単に
ブランクができますよパン捏ねますほっに家事
万事 ok ほぼろずじゃぁオッシャーンっ
おっしゃ ok 理由ん
ああああああ
バンカーリングの卒完成しました津山のバンカーリングのリングに起毛としますたーっ
こんなにいらないよ
あ着ればいいのかああ
やりましたダメだこれこれやばいら多分直せないポットポッとんぱんっ
4もう
おーせず通してみます1回逃走
パパちゃんはちゃん度を通りせ前もをくぐり抜け
尿道から
生まれていきますいいんじゃあいいよいいよブランコと一緒になるな
カードね滑るこれをこの椅子にくくりつけてブラックの完成ですそもそもここで行くか
どうかが勝負ですから
ん
ok じゃないですかまあここがで買える余裕で普段その場で差分落ちることはないと
思う
はいかつてですね
音響極圏現在本物じゃんっ
魚ブランコ弾
マジもんだよこれはすごいね待ってよねパスブランコ使った
特に問題なく動いておりますブランコつ台が完成しました
あとは京都の問題だ本物の遊具っていうのはどんなに重い人が乗っても壊れな注意書き
がなければなぁ法しかしねぇんだよなぁ見せっこでしょ
ipad 20個分でしょ絶対いけるよいやーちょっと緊張してきちゃうんだ
1回切ります
はいという実績が移動してみましょうこれはいけるぞ
いやー
see
2バーン
エイ